¿Qué pasó en Crijo?
Entramos en la puerta,
llevaron para un local,
vino un barbero,
y totó esperarlo a mi señora.
¿Y qué pasó?
La señora se fue.
Le llamo a mi señora,
le pido perdón a mí,
y ya estábamos listos.
Ya era la tarde,
a las seis ya era comida,
ya no quería hablar de comida,
y el perro
no dormía aquí,
en el piso de cemento.
Nada abajo.
Perro, tú tienes que dormir en el piso,
en concreto.
¿Y la comida qué?
Ya estaba terminado,
a las seis, allá mire,
cuando el timbre tocó,
ya tenía que estar con su...
con su poquito de comida,
después de las seis, ya la cocina cerrada.
Tú sabes cómo eran,
a las siete de la noche,
y a las seis de la noche.
Ya.
Y en la mañana,
veinte como yo dormía en un piso de concreto.
¿Con cuánta gente? ¿Cuánta gente había en ese piso?
Nosotros dos.
¿Solos? ¿Durmieron solos?
Sí, nosotros separados.
Allá era, allí era, mire,
mínimo mil cárcolos, ¿no?
Mil cárcolos.
Era con más que cien mil personas,
en esa concentración lana.
¿Y eran casitas pequeñas?
Pequeñas.
De...
de techo de paja,
y paredes de cinque.
De cinque, estábamos aquí a cinque.
¿Y qué tenía? ¿Para dormir?
¿Y tenía baños?
Por favor,
ya yo no quiero decir qué era.
¿Qué era?
Más peor que uno se puede presentar.
Bueno.
Descríbamelo.
Para baños, cada uno hizo un piso.
Y en la mañana tenía limpiar de contrapos, cada uno.
Su sitio.
Comida era,
si ustedes saben,
antiguas mujeres
tenían, se llamaba,
un trozo para reinar,
biznik.
Y en esto iban a comer todo el mundo.
Veganza.
¿Usted me entiende?
Más miserable que puede ser.
Gente que ya murieron
como moscas.
¿Qué le daban de comer de desayuno?
¿De desayuno qué comía?
Era así.
Dos papas,
medio crudo,
con un
zanahorio
y agua caliente.
Eso era desayuno.
¿Y almuerzo?
El almuerzo
era un café negro.
Nada más.
Ese era desayuno.
¿Y cena?
Era más miserable
que puede ser.
La gente se lo aguantaron.
¿Qué era de cena?
¿Qué comía de cena?
Es igual lo que comieron.
No era otra cosa.
¿Las papas?
Mire, ¿usted sabe qué es hambre?
¿Entonces qué hacía? ¿Dormía?
Yo...
te digo la verdad.
Este críos
era 12 kilómetros
de mi seredera.
Tenía que pasar un campo.
Yo era capaz de huir.
No, mi señora, no me dejó.
Y si Dios ayudó a nosotros
a salir del genitorio,
el Dios
va a ayudar
salir también
de acá también.
Yo estuve en Críos
de domingo la noche
hasta viernes
a las nueve de la mañana.
¿En qué trabajó durante ese tiempo?
Nada.
Nosotros dos no tuvimos trabajo.
¿Por qué?
No sé.
¿Usted me pregunta por qué?
Puro, inesto,
cuarto,
todo el tiempo nos dieron
algo por debajo de la roca,
algo en el piso,
y a día y noche allá.
¿No trabajó en nada?
No tenía derecho
salir de allá.
Ya trajeron
esa comida crítica, idiota.
¿Tenía contacto con otras personas?
Nada.
¿Por qué?
No puede ser.
¿Por qué? No sé.
¿Quién era?
¿Por qué?
Si era orden, si no era orden,
no podía contestar.
Ese polaco
que yo controlaba,
sacaron de crematorio
e inmediatamente
se fue y habló con mi hermano.
Y mi hermano,
no sé qué fue,
estaba muy miedoso,
muy miedoso,
y logró hablar con ese
lector,
dice que era Helmut Bloch.
A las nueve de la mañana
llegó
el...
¿Cómo se dice?
No era Carlos, ¿no?
Era cuatro ruberos
con dos caballos,
una... ¿Cómo se dice?
Carreta.
Y traía orden
de Old Summer
que tiene que regresar
para su trabajo
y entregar
a Carlos Helmut Bloch.
Pocos días,
ya liquidaron todo,
liquidación.
Yo escondía a mi señora,
yo huyó,
¿Cómo huyó?
De botada.
¿Usted volvió al gueto otra vez?
Ya, mire,
¿a dónde voy, mire?
Allá, no sabía, pero también
se me había escondido.
Era mayo del 43.
Era más o menos
siete días,
siete días, sí.
Estaban como cuatro días
escondidos allá, nada más.
¿En dónde, en el gueto?
Sí, en la comida,
adonde uno estaba,
allá hice todo
y yo le dí
que no aguantamos.
Entonces yo dije a mi señora,
eh,
necesitado,
ya he liquidado el gueto esta mañana.
¿Y ustedes estaban ahí?
Escondíamos la noche,
cuando ya es buena la vida.
¿Pero ya no había más nadie?
Yo,
mi hermano,
la señora de él y yo.
¿Y no había otro judío en el gueto?
¿Cuántos lo preguntaron
sin comer y sin
beber y sin nada?
Cuando usted dice que liquidaron el gueto,
¿qué hicieron con el gueto?
¿Cuántos liquidaron?
Murieron.
¿Y las personas allá adentro, qué pasó?
Todo.
¿Y usted estaba allí?
Toditas.
Llegaron todos para el cementerio.
¿Y a usted no lo llevaron?
¿Por qué?
No podía llegarme.
Estaba en el búnker.
¿Cómo era el búnker?
El búnker, por ejemplo, mire, allá mire,
era, aquí estaban
ocho pisos. Allá montaba,
eran pocos edificios, casas
bajas, ¿sí? Piso de tablas.
Entonces uno quitó
las tablas, hizo
la tierra y tapado con
tablas, ¿me entiende?
Y hizo un corte de dos tablas como portica.
¿Me entiende?
Que no se sabía
si es piso, si es
portica, uno no podía
conocer, ¿me entiende? Es el búnker.
Mire, después, mire,
polacos ayudaban a alemanes.
Pusieron oídos para piso.
Allí está, mire,
allá.
Polacos ayudaban a muchos,
muchos, muchos alemanes.
Y así, mire,
pasó
la vida.
Y yo con mi hermano
huyó del viato.